bonjour à toutes et à tous vous avez vu
en france en été il fait plus en plus
chaud
franchement ça va
toujours taxer cher concrètement ça
implique que vous transpirez beaucoup
trop et que vos camarades de métro sont
un petit peu mauvais mais en plus ça 2,3
conséquences sur notre environnement les
lacs s'assèche les vignes aussi les
poissons meurent et les moustiques nous
emmerde mais aujourd'hui on va vous
parler des arbres parce que c'est
important les arbres
[Musique]
et oui c'est une vraie question ça
comment les arbres de nos belles forêts
vont-ils encaissé 7 aridi fication du
climat pour le savoir il va nous falloir
prendre de la hauteur
direction les alpes de haute provence à
3 mètres 50 du sol sur un site
exceptionnel l'autre au hp il a été
développé au sein d'une forêt naturelle
de chêne pubescent pour observer au plus
près leur adaptation face au changement
climatique
cet endroit permet de sculpter la forêt
de la tête aux pieds mais aussi de la
faire voyager dans le temps en voyant à
quoi elle pourra ressembler dans le
futur la base du dispositif c'est une
plate forme longue de dix mètres qui a
été installé à deux niveaux de hauteur
différente à 3 mètres 50 et à 80 cm pour
pouvoir observer à la fois la canopée
mais aussi les troncs des arbres ensuite
les scientifiques ont mis en place une
expérience pour comparer trois parcelles
dans la première on a construit un
dispositif composé de vola hermétique
qui permettent d'intercepter 30 à 40% de
la pluie pour simuler un climat aride
sur cette parcelle de la forêt
les chercheurs peuvent les ouvrir et les
fermer à leur guise en fonction de la
météo bon là par exemple on était à
quelques minutes d'un énorme orage
mais c'est horrible mais c'est pas du
tout détox comme régiment c'est l'envers
ce qu'il faut faire il faut leur donner
du jus d'épinards ou baies de goji est
et aider des soucis au brocoli et choux
raves ces arbres artificiellement
confronté un changement climatiques
sévères sont ensuite comparés à ceux
d'une parcelle témoin l'essai face à
notre climat actuel soumis à des
précipitations normales ils sont aussi
comparé à des arbres d'une parcelle
irriguées qui échappent donc à la
sécheresse estivale naturel mais alors
du coup comment on compare dans ce
système d'exclusion depuis dynamique des
dizaines de capteurs permettent de
mesurer si paramètres environnementaux
comme la température l'humidité et ce à
différents niveaux du sol et de la
canopée
le but comprendre la corrélation entre
ces paramètres et l'évolution de la
santé des arbres on s'occupe donc de
prendre le pouls des chaînes transformé
en véritable rats de laboratoire grâce à
des capteurs permettant de mesurer les
flux de sève plus l'arbre et rigoureux
plus la sève monte vite plus l'arbre
grandira comme un ado un peu la force de
l'autre au hpc qu'on ne s'occupe pas
uniquement de l'arbre isolé mais de
l'arbre au sein de son écosystème
c'est à dire dans une forêt naturelle
dans toute sa complexité où cohabitent
de nombreuses espèces végétales et
animales des analyses précises sont donc
également menée sur le sol dans lequel
les arbres sont plantés du coup les
scientifiques dissèque la forêt à tous
les niveaux de la cime des arbres à
leurs racines en s'intéressant aussi à
l'aération des sols grâce a déclenché en
verre et oui on dit souvent que les
forêts sont les poumons de notre planète
sauf que pour que les arbres fassent
leur boulot et nous aident à respirer il
faut que la terre qui les accueillent
respire elle aussi et n'oublions pas non
plus qu'un arbre a besoin de se nourrir
pour cela il faut que les matières
organiques qu'il rejette sous forme de
feuilles mortes soit recyclés en
produisant de la biomasse et donc des
nutriments vous savez le fameux
phosphore et le célèbre azote dont nous
avons parlé dans notre vidéo sur les
toilettes du futur tueur c'est tout
eh ben les arbres aussi ils en ont
besoin et pour ça ils doivent compter
sur des petits animaux qui vivent juste
à leurs pieds et qu'on appelle la maiso
faune la maiso phone c'est la faune qui
a une taille comprise entre 0,2 et 4 mm
ça inclut des animaux comme les acariens
les colons bol et autres arthropodes
trop mignon en vain trop mignon non en
vrai ils sont laids comme dépouille mais
on va pas se mentir ils sont très utiles
en tout cas ils mangent les feuilles
mortes et contrôler la prolifération des
micro organismes dans les sols ils sont
ensuite consommés par des insectes de
plus grande taille comme les araignées
ou les pseudos scorpions qui eux-mêmes
nourriront les oiseaux etc etc vous
connaissez le principe ça s'appelle la
chaîne alimentaire et c'est nous qui
gagnons à la fin sauf contre la plupart
des ours les chercheurs leur porte donc
une attention toute particulière et pour
savoir comment ils se sentent en milieu
aride il faut retourner sur le terrain
voici des back permettant de récolter la
litière au pied des arbres afin de
quantifier la production de biomasse en
fonction du contexte climatique
heureusement à l'autre au hp on est
équipés pour mener une démarche
scientifique de a à z on peut donc
passer directement du terrain au
laboratoire pour observer tout ça ici on
récupère toutes les petites bébêtes
présente dans ce sol on les observe à la
loupe binoculaire pour identifier tout
ce petit monde et hop on peut dresser la
courbe de population de la maiso faune
en fonction de l'évolution du climat et
là
le tableau est pas jojo en cas d' harry
dit et les organismes détritivores
meurent plus facilement que leurs
prédateurs et cette chute démographique
importante ralenti le processus de
décomposition des sols ce qui impacte
alors toute la biodiversité c'est à
grande échelle et là vous allez me dire
sans acquérir de plus ou de moins qu'est
ce que ça peut vous faire franchement
vous cherchez toujours la petite bête
vous les écolos un
ballon parce que si tu affaiblis un
maillon de la chaîne c'est toute la
faune qui se retrouve en danger un
puceron qui meurt c'est potentiellement
une coccinelle affamés
[Musique]
or ces petites bêtes là sont essentiels
à l'entretien d'une belle structuration
du sol on dit même que les vers de terre
sont les ingénieurs du sol c'est dire et
un seul mal structuré ça peut causer d
érosion des terres arables donc une
baisse de la fertilité des chants et
même des glissements de terrain qui
fragiliseront nos constructions alors
pour garder ta ville là en place et au
frigo bien plein tu ferais bien de
protéger les petites bêtes
bon soyons calme et posée est ce que
c'est vraiment le début de l'apocalypse
pour le moment le chêne pubescent
résiste plutôt bien à la diminution
simuler des précipitations même s'ils
encaissent une légère baisse de
croissance il est résilient le chêne
enfin pour l'instant car pour le moment
les scientifiques peuvent observer de
légère tendance mais c'est dur de savoir
s'il le sera encore dans cinquante ans
et ça c'est le drame parce que le chêne
pubescent c'est quand même le papa de la
truffe mois mais non pas toi le jus de
champignons enfin l'entrée ce qui se
mange quoi et autant vivent dans un
monde sans acariens à moi ça me va
autant vivre dans un monde sans truffe
no way heureusement les chercheurs de
l'eau 3 hp tire des conclusions
précieuse de leurs recherches pour
limiter l'impact négatif de la
réunification grâce à leur savoir ils
peuvent aider à la gestion forestière de
demain et on va en avoir besoin parce
que des campagnes de plantation d'arbres
sont actuellement mises en place pour
atténuer les effets du changement
climatique et injecter de l'argent pour
planter des forêts c'est bien mais
éviter de planter un chêne peu
résistants qui va crever dans trois ans
c'est mieux pour pas passer pour un
gland nos experts donnent donc des
pistes pour re faut rester la france
avec des essences plus approprié pour
effectuer une transition tout en douceur
leur conseil éviter de planter des
espèces mono spécifiques en effet
certains arbres sont naturellement
accompagnée de type de plante qui leur
font du bien c'est ce qu'on appelle les
espèces compagnes la préservation de ces
groupe de potes chlorophylle et aide à
la bonne santé de la forêt toute entière
la solution pour une france qui respire
à pleins poumons verts c'est donc la
diversité forestière et après tout si au
final on a moins de truffes moines
blancs ça nous ferait de l'air merci à
tous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo on
espère que ça vous aura plu et que ça
vous aura donné envie de chouchouter nos
forêts qui morfle un peu plus chaque été
alors n'oubliez pas ne jetez pas vos
mégots triez vos déchets abonnez vous à
cette chaîne est là chez nous un pouce
bleus
est abonnez vous à cette chaîne
chaîne
[Rires]